- I'm super fired up to be here.
Thank you so much for having me.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
There's several different
things running through my mind
but let me start with this
because I want to get a sense
for the audience.
How many people here are entrepreneurs?
Raise your hand.
Very nice, thank you.
Quite a bit.
Working in a small business?
Very nice.
Corporate jobs?
Great.
Now everyone's like, man, fuck.
(audience laughing loudly)
Awesome, that's what I needed.
Looking at the hands,
here's where I want to go this evening.
I think the biggest
thing that is on my mind
as I stand here tonight,
and I appreciate the wonderful welcome,
is including myself, and
fuck, I spend every minute
trying to understand all of this,
I think that everybody in
here is underestimating
how special this era is.
Whether you're a young kid and never knew
a non-internet world, whether
you're my age, 42, or above
and you understood it because
we grew up without it,
even the people that can appreciate it
because we grew up without it,
I don't think are really understanding
that this internet thing is
no question the biggest change
in the human race, ever.
It just is.
All the things we're thinking about,
whether it's political or
social or financial things,
they've just started.
Everything that's
changing has just started.
I think this amazing
state has a lot of pride
and some of the great companies
that have come out of it,
in my adulthood, not even in my childhood,
Best Buy rose and was eliminated
because of this environment.
I'll be honest with you,
I mean, it's tough to say
but I actually think Target
is remarkably vulnerable
in an Amazon/Walmart battle world.
I actually predict, pretty
aggressively, that Target
will be bought by either
Amazon or Facebook or Apple
or Google because I think
the internet companies
have to buy retail to compete with Amazon.
I guess the thing that I think about is
how many 11-year-olds are
making a million dollars a year
selling slime on Instagram.
(audience chuckling)
A lot.
Like, hundreds.
Let me just, let's just, you know what,
I think it's a funny thing
and I can see you guys
are picking up what I'm putting down.
Hundreds of 11-year-olds
make a million dollars a year
selling slime.
At the same token, the
top 1% earners in America,
financially, start at $400,000,
$400-something thousand a year.
You hear about Instagram or an
11-year-old making a million,
it's crazy to me what
runs through all the SMBs,
small business and entrepreneurs, in here.
A million is like waking up.
Making a million or having
a million dollar business,
that's just kind of normal.
The way this room, this
state, this country, the game
thinks about building a million
dollar business is like,
oh, one in every other one of us,
50% of us are going to
do that, yet it's 1%.
There's a real, real
disconnect between the reality
of what's happening, all the opportunity,
and so what I think is
happening is this extremism.
Much like our social issues
where we're starting to
really go in opposite directions,
there's this extremism of,
yes, there are hundreds
of 11-year-olds making a
million fucking dollars a year,
making slime, selling it on Instagram,
yet 99% of people that
raise $2 million in capital
for their start-up to make the
Uber a fucking pizza delivery
are going to fail.
I'm trying to think about
what am I talking about,
what's driving me?
I think the thing that's
grounding me is in this
ridiculous change in our society,
things like 15 years ago,
if you dated on the internet
and dated somebody you met
on the internet that that was,
you were weird and a loser
and it was taboo, and
now every single person
dates through the internet and
swipes left and right 24/7,
or slides into the DM.
(audience laughing)
Do you know how crazy Uber
is, an an early investor?
Uber's insane.
Uber, or Lyft, or whatever
you want, literally,
if I stood up here and said guys,
in 15 years you're going to want
your 13-year-old daughter
to go into a stranger's car,
because you're going to think
that's safer than her driving
with her friend, like literally,
in high net worth towns
across America now, on the
16th, or 17th, or 15th birthday,
the gift of choice, if
you're in a rich area,
is unlimited Uber for the kid.
Kids don't want cars.
Kids in the suburbs are
not getting licenses
if they're in a high net worth environment
because they'd rather
just have unlimited Uber
and parents actually,
and probably correctly,
think it's safer for
their 16-year-old daughter
to go into strange 40-year-old men cars
multiple times a day.
(audience laughing loudly)
I mean it.
But I would have never been
able to sell you on that
if this was 10 years ago and I'm like,
let's do start-up ideas
and I pitched you on that,
you would have laughed me out of the room.
I know because I laughed
the founders of Uber
out of the room when they were like,
what if everybody could
get a limo on their iPhone?
I was like, yeah, 1% of rich people.
I never saw it playing out the way it did.
I don't know, I think it's
a very interesting time
but what's interesting to me about it is
as the world's changing, as
people watching video games,
more people watch people play video games
than watch people play baseball.
That's just real.
By the way, back to it just started,
there's no baseball, Bryce
Harper and Mike Trout combined
on their best day are
1/10 as famous as Ninja is
to 14-year-olds in America.
(audience chuckling)
But that's not what we grew up with
and so all these things
that are happening, guys,
ABC, NBC, and CBS are finished.
They're done.
Remember when four years ago
you had one show on Netflix
that you liked but then you watched cable?
Now you have Netflix and
there's one show on cable
or regular TV.
Do you understand when all
the sports go to Netflix
and Amazon.
Amazon has bought the rights
to English premiere football,
you know, proper football, soccer shit.
(audience laughing loudly)
Tennis, Amazon's going to
be bidding for the NFL.
Hulu's going to have hockey.
Google and Apple are
going to have basketball.
You're never going to turn
on two, four, five, or seven.
Ever.
In this world, think about
nothing we believe in or use,
YouTube, the iPhone, Netflix, Facebook,
none of that existed 15 years ago.
Nothing that our entire
society is running on,
who was not alive 15 years ago?
Raise your hand.
Good.
We were all here.
(audience laughing loudly)
I'm a little pissed
that my 13-year-old fans
didn't come out tonight but.
(audience laughing)
Everything we run on,
guys, almost everybody here
remembers the world pre-smartphone.
You couldn't, it's just five
minutes ago that you were like
the internet on your phone!
(audience chuckling)
We struggle with things.
Parents all the time,
when SnapChat blew up
three or four years
ago, parents were like,
Gary, but I don't want my kid on SnapChat.
I'm like, you do know your son has Safari
and can type in JizzHut.com, right?
(audience laughing loudly)
You're worried about the
one floozy 13-year-old
in the fucking state
and the dude's got porn
at his fucking fingertips.
(audience laughing loudly)
Ha ha ha.
That's what I think a lot about,
which is nobody here
has actually quantified
what's really happened here.
For example, there's a
term in start-up land
or in business world called the last mile.
It's this big debate of
how we're all going to get
everything delivered to us within an hour.
Is it going to be Amazon,
is it going to be Uber,
is it going to be Postmates?
What I don't think
people understand is 7-11
is actually out of business
in the next 15 years,
20 years because of the last mile.
You need deodorant or a
fucking 20 ounce Mountain Dew,
you're going to press a
button and it's going to be
in your fucking house
or office in a second.
What I don't, what I think
I've done really well
in my career by launching a
wine business on the internet
in 1996 when people told me
the internet itself was a fad.
Or buying Google Ad words
when nobody even knew
what a search engine really was.
Or when I started a wine show on YouTube
in the first six months it existed.
Or went all in on social
media when everybody
shit on social media, I was there.
I remember what everybody
thought about Twitter
and how stupid it was.
Or that Facebook was a college thing.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Is that we are bad at
understanding the present
and the future and we love to
put the past on a pedestal.
Somebody said to me yesterday, Gary,
but what about looking a man in the eyes
when you talk to him?
I'm like, what about it?
(audience laughing loudly)
That means you don't think
people should write letters
or talk on the phone.
We put the past on a pedestal.
We demonize the current and the future.
In all these changes, in all
of this stuff that is going on,
the thing that is most fascinating to me
and thing that I want to talk
to you about is that this,
doing the right thing
and gratitude and honor
and all this propaganda that I push,
is actually more valuable than
ever because let me tell you
what the internet's going to do.
I've been saying this for a long time
and I feel like people are
finally starting to believe me
because of the Me Too movement
and many other things.
The internet is going to expose all of us.
Our society has been groomed and has lived
in the shadows of our society.
Our institutions, our beliefs,
this has all be sustained
by the darkness.
Like all those fuckers
in the second section,
I can't see you for shit,
you're dark as fuck.
(audience laughing)
When people yell at me, I
had this woman yelling at me,
friend, she wasn't yelling at me, well,
she was yelling at me over dinner
about how this internet
thing is scary and it sucks
and this and that.
And she's an incredible
activist for all women's rights
and all these other things.
I'm like, you do
understand that your media
that you're putting on a pedestal,
the New York Times and NBC, is
the reason all this bad stuff
was able to happen.
Yeah, Kathleen, that's exactly right.
(audience laughing)
When five or six old white
guys control the media,
a lot of stuff doesn't hit daylight.
When we control the media
it gets a lot harder.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Let me give you a news alert.
Russia didn't make you do anything.
(audience laughing,
cheering, and applauding)
It didn't, it didn't.
Meaning, if you're a good
person, a bad person,
voted Democrat or Republican,
dit dit dit dit do,
you do you.
I have zero interest in debating politics
with anybody these days
because everyone's on tilt.
I just want everybody to know,
the Russians didn't
hack your fucking brain.
You didn't go in saying I'm
going to vote for Hillary,
and vote for Donald, or
the other way around.
That's not what happened.
What happened is, you believe
in what you want to believe.
Technology's exposing
us, it's not changing us.
(audience cheering and applauding)
What's happening, where does this all go?
What I want you to do more than anything
is understand the following.
It has never been a better
time in the human race ever
to actually just go all in on you.
The thing that I've realized
all these chess moves go to
is judgment is the poison in the system.
We are all doing so much
based on our worries
or our pandering to judgment.
We buy things we can't afford
because we want to look good
to everybody else.
Parents quietly subsidize
kids' lives in their 20s
because they want other parents to think
their kid's doing well.
But what they're actually doing
is creating a fake
environment for that kid
and eliminating their self-esteem
and then that kid becomes entitled
and everybody's fucking pissed.
(audience chuckling)
The kid, the parent, and it
gets real fucked up real fast.
Kid's out here posturing
like they're an entrepreneur
but mommy's paying for the gym pass.
(audience chuckling)
There's a ton of shit
going on and what I think,
I sit and I watch and I
watch and I watch and I ask
why is this working, why have
I been putting out content
for a decade but the last
18 months has worked more,
better, different.
Am I better at understanding
Instagram and podcasts
and YouTube or is the
message that I'm talking
finding the right timing?
Is it important, is it
right, is it tried and true,
are we ready for it, are
we not, what's happening?
Here's what's happening.
We are in a remarkable time.
For all the things you
may be worried about,
left, right, up, down, there
has never been a better time
to be alive in the human
race than right now.
Medicine, life expectancy,
poverty, every issue we have,
better.
The best people to talk about
what's going on in America
are 90-year-olds.
They shit on everybody.
(audience chuckling)
They're like, she thinks it's bad?
Ah, fuck!
This woman made me laugh so hard.
This like 92-year-old woman
stopped me in the street,
she's like, keep doing what you're doing.
I'm like, I mean, she looked like 190.
(audience laughing)
I was like, thank you.
I got to talk to her for
a second and she's like,
by the way, these women,
and she's wrong but it was still funny,
these women, fuck, if I didn't
have somebody grab my ass
everyday in the office, I was pissed!
I was like, I get it.
(audience laughing loudly)
I was like, don't say that in public.
She's like, fuck public!
(audience laughing loudly)
I was like, man, 92 is some gangster shit.
(audience laughing)
I'm obsessed with practicality.
People think I'm a destructor
or Nostrad-, a predictor.
I'm practical.
Facebook and Instagram ads
are grossly under-priced.
If you go how tonight and Google
how to run Instagram story
ads, and learn how to do that,
and then make a video or picture
and run Instagram story ads
for whatever you're trying to do in life,
become the mayor here, sell
some peanuts, kombucha,
get people to sign up for
your fucking track team,
I don't care what,
I don't know where the
fuck this shit comes from.
(audience laughing loudly)
I don't even think you can sign
people up for a track team.
(audience laughing)
Anyway, nonetheless.
An Instagram story ad will
work better than anything else
you can do if you care about people 15-55.
Fifteen to 45.
If you care about people 30-75,
Facebook works better than anything.
All your dreams, whatever that may be,
simple dreams like
making $400 more a month
so you can save it and take your family
to Walt Disney this year.
All your dreams.
The amount of people that
are affected by making
$200 more a month is staggering.
The fact that I know if you
literally stop listening to me
right now, took out your
phone, went to Craigslist,
went to the For Sale section,
clicked on the Free section
within the For Sale section,
took your fucking car,
got up, left in the middle of my keynote
and picked up eight things, went home,
took one picture on your fucking phone,
not like fucking old days
where the fucking phone,
you take the disk out and put
it in your fucking computer.
No, not that.
Which is, oh by the way, the old days,
you know, 11 years ago.
(audience chuckling)
No, just take a picture
of the fucking thing
and post it on Facebook
Marketplace and post it
for $20 to $80, that literally
in the next 48 hours,
you would have $200 more.
I'm obsessed with practicality.
Everything I talk about feels so real,
it just might take 11
years and a lot of people
don't have 11 years.
They don't have 11 years
because they're not willing
to put in the work to be happy
for the rest of their life.
They'd rather complain, they'd
rather blame somebody else.
The biggest thing that's
happening in America and the world
is a lack of accountability.
You want to really know what
the fuck's happening here?
A lack of accountability.
(audience applauding)
For me, for me, forget
about it because I am doing
more of the normal for who knows why,
undertones of the politic thing.
If you sit here tonight and you are not
completely fucking pumped about your life,
it's up to you to change that.
But if this was 1987, and I
mean this on everything I love,
I wouldn't have a lot of energy for you,
I wouldn't even stand up
here and talk about it,
I wouldn't have the
audacity to bullshit you
that you could do something about it,
because it wasn't practical.
Who's got a smartphone?
Raise your hand.
Actually, who doesn't?
(audience laughing)
Hold on, dude, seriously
in the yellow, you don't?
Please come up here, I need to see you.
(audience applauding loudly)
I need to see what this man is.
Get up here, bro.
Right over there.
Hurry up, dude.
(audience laughing)
This is amazing.
Thank you.
Hello.
How are you?
What's your name, what's your name?
- Rod.
- Rod, where are you from?
- Rochester.
- Let's clap it up.
(audience applauding loudly)
You do not have a smartphone?
- I don't have a smartphone.
- You have a flip phone?
- I have nothing.
(audience moaning)
I have a tablet, but,
I don't use it as a phone.
- So.
(audience laughing loudly).
Thursday afternoon, you're leaving work
like you don't have a phone?
- Right.
- Now, you once had a smartphone
and you've started fighting the system?
- Yes.
- Why are you fighting the system?
- Because I believe talking to people
and getting to know people
is a lot more powerful
than talking to somebody on the internet.
- Real quick, though.
Doesn't that mean that some
other human has to exist
that doesn't have a phone?
- Ha ha, (inaudible).
(audience laughing)
- I understand.
Guys, this is a national treasure.
(audience cheering)
Let's clap it up for this pioneer.
(audience applauding loudly)
Thanks for coming tonight.
- Yeah.
- That's incredible.
- Awesome show.
- Fucking rare.
That is a, literally, you
could bring a fucking alien
from Mars right now and
I would look at that
as more common than this
incredible gentleman.
(audience laughing)
If you're everybody but Rod
and you have this, you
literally can do anything.
The fact that, this is
where shit gets crazy to me,
the fact that this is more
powerful of a computer
than what Ronald Reagan
had running the free world
is fucking crazy.
Right?
It's crazy!
You can do anything.
Literally every person here
lay up, unless all of you do it
because then that would
fuck up the Craigslist
supply and demand curve,
but everybody here
literally could make $1000 more.
I came up with this 2017 flip challenge
where I talked about yard
sales and thrift stops
and dollar stores and it
really helped a lot of people.
Just people on welfare or needed $50 more,
it was really amazing.
But then, of course,
you always have somebody
fucking looking for an
excuse and they're like,
well, what if you have no money?
I'm a really weird fucker,
I'm like, I would jump in
and be like, yo, Pants87,
what do you mean by none?
You have too many, zero,
and it would go into this
and people would troll it.
Then all of a sudden I
was like, wait a minute,
I don't want to hear that anymore.
I'm going to figure out what happens
if you actually have no money.
Zero.
This whole Craigslist to
Facebook thing is remarkable.
It's free.
You literally go to somebody's house,
they give it to you happily
because they don't want
an old TV anymore or a hammock
or a fucking trampoline.
They're usually big things
so you need fucking trucks
but that's good because I've
been here for about 20 minutes
and there's a lot of fucking trucks here.
(audience laughing loudly)
So you're set.
Listing on Facebook is free.
This is not even like eBay,
like dollar list, it's all free.
People can make $100, $1000, $2000 a month
if they're willing to eat shit.
See, because it takes shit
to always be on your phone
and be on free when the person lists it.
It takes shit to be in a
suburb of main towns like this
where you might have to drive 55 minutes
to pick up that thing.
There's gas cost and this
and that and I get that.
It takes shit to do that.
It's funny.
This really has caught on.
There's like a whole meme
going on the internet right now
because there's a bunch of people
literally riding on subways with couches.
(audience laughing)
There's this whole viral thing
going on and some of my fans
know it's me and they're
like, it's fucking Gary Vee!
Where I'm going with this little story
is I'm so flabbergasted that
the excuses have been
eliminated by the internet.
See, what I love about the internet is
it doesn't know who you are,
doesn't care where you came from,
what nationality you are,
gender, income level.
If you're just willing to
work your fucking face off,
you can get there.
The problem is,
there's something that
I'm very fascinated with,
which is called entitlement.
It goes into the thing of judgment.
A lot of ding on me and
say, Gary, this is working
but a problem, I don't have a
car, I have to take the bus,
I did what you said and I
did have this chair with me
on the bus but everybody
was looking at me.
It was, it's super powerful
because the shit we worry about
in third grade is the
shit we worry about today.
I literally wrote him back.
I was like, yo, you are
in a place in your life
where you need $20, right?
Really, the stranger on the
bus is your fucking problem?
(audience chuckling)
You should be pumped, you should be proud,
document that shit, right?
I'm thinking a lot about
privilege in a lot of ways
but I've come to realize
the ultimate privilege
is being right up here.
To me, if I could have any
dream, my dream would be
that we could map the
human DNA and figure out
what self esteem is and pump it
into everybody's fucking body 24/7/365.
(audience applauding)
Because when you actually
have self esteem,
you have empathy for others,
you don't care what they think about you,
you do, it gets really
quiet here and you do.
I can't implore this
audience enough to realize
that Facebook and Instagram right now
is so remarkably
under-priced in its ability
to change the outcome of
your business, your dreams,
your mission, your name, and
that a lot of people here
have opinions about what to
do on Facebook and Instagram,
how good or bad does it work,
but you've never used it.
You've never really run a Facebook ad,
you've never really run an Instagram ad.
You have opinions, you pontificate,
but you're not a practitioner.
If I could do anything today,
it would be to encourage people to go home
and Google how to run Facebook ads,
how to run Instagram ads,
because that will
absolutely change your game.
How many people here are running
Facebook or Instagram ads?
Raise your hands.
Let me tell you something
else, raise them higher,
just curious.
A lot, which is great.
How many of those people
feel like it's successful
and they're happy with what's going on?
Stand up actually.
Stand up.
(bottle rolling across the floor)
(audience laughing)
You could sell that bottle for 10 cents.
Here's my thing, for
everybody who's not or,
and let's be honest right here,
keep standing if you don't mind,
how many people here,
and this is very fair
because it's happened to me so
I want to make you feel safe,
but it's important to me,
how many people here have
run Facebook or Instagram ads
and it didn't work?
Raise your hands.
Notice how many that are
standing are doing it as well.
I think about this all the time.
The ROI.
Thank you, you can sit, thank you.
The ROI of a basketball, some
of you have heard me say this,
for LeBron it's a billion
dollars, for me it's zero.
Just because you didn't have
a successful ad campaign
on Facebook or Instagram
doesn't mean it doesn't work,
it means you suck.
(audience chuckling)
I'm serious.
It means you sucked.
If you don't run a successful
ad campaign right now
on Facebook and Instagram
in the way that it's so under-priced,
you actually really suck.
Now, here's the good news.
A lot of people run ads
that are self serving.
The reason so many things
aren't working for people
is because it's good for you,
not for the other person.
Nobody wants your $897 bullshit e-book.
That's why your fucking
Facebook ad didn't work.
That's the problem, not Facebook.
I really, really, really
want to implore people
to understand that I sit here
with a lot of business regret
because when my dad's business
grew from $3 to $60 million,
it should have been
from $3 to $250 million.
But I didn't run enough Google ads.
I figured it out, I hit
pay dirt, and guess what,
somebody bought beachfront
property in Malibu,
and only bought one house
when she could have afforded four.
She regrets it for the rest of time.
Somebody who's digging
for gold and found some
and then just left because
he felt like we were good,
it ran out, and then watched
10 more years of gold
being found.
On and on and on.
I hit hard on Google when it first popped
but I didn't spend enough
because I was a kid
and I didn't realize how
special that moment was.
That moment went away.
Buying the word cabernet
and Merlot and pinot grigio
and Bordeaux and Napa
Valley and wine and wines
and wine gifts and this
and that, they were five
and 10 cents a click.
I bought them all and nobody knew
what the fuck was happening.
There was millions of people on Google
and I got bigger than Haskell's and Sam's
and Sherry Lehman's and Wine Club
and everybody was confused why.
That's what's happening right
now on Facebook and Instagram.
I'm telling you the fucking
truth, I'm giving it to you,
and 98% of you will not
do anything about it.
That fucks with me heavy.
I'm literally giving it to you here
and you're saying, nieh.
To me, when people ask me,
why the fuck do you give away
all your best shit,
that's where you could
make all your money?
It's because 98% of you
are not going to do anything about it.
And for the 2%, when I see
you in line and you tell me
I changed your life or this and that,
that admiration feels phenomenal,
and I still get to make all the money
because 98% of you fuck-faces
are not going to do
anything about it!
(audience applauding)
You need to ask yourself tonight,
why it's more interesting
to dwell and complain
and come up with excuses
than actually be happy.
I'll save you time.
Your mom fucked you up.
(audience chuckling)
So, cool.
Or your dad.
Or your older brother.
Or some circumstance.
Here's my big thing, I'm looking around
and even for the geezers in here,
you're all living for
another 50 fucking years.
Minimum.
There's people in here.
(audience applauding)
Right?
I mean, dude, I know
you're like, fuck, awesome.
When you were kids
you're like 60, fuck it.
Now.
(audience laughing)
Now, right?
But you know what's crazy?
Now it is nuts.
How many people here are under 30?
All of you outside of, by that scale,
almost all of you get to 100, 110 easy.
That's fucking nuts.
You're freaking out you turned 30
and you are fucking living
for another 90 fucking years!
(audience laughing loudly)
You're like, I don't
have my shit together.
I'm like, you haven't even
fucking started, dick.
(audience laughing)
I'm about to make this video about 18,
it's going to be called, 18, 22, 30.
These are the three ages that
everybody just gets fucked.
For some reason at 18, 22, and 30,
you have to have every
fucking thing figured out.
These fucking 59-year-old
parents are like,
you've got to get your shit together
and they still have no clue
what the fuck they're doing.
(audience laughing and applauding)
Meanwhile, somebody at 15
knows what they're doing.
To me, this age thing, it's like sports.
Is experience better
because, I don't know,
I saw 18 year old LeBron
and Kobe dominate.
This is a talent game, this
is a self-awareness game.
This is do you have your
shit together up here game.
Are you letting somebody
else dictate your happiness?
Who, how, what?
It's all interesting to me
because it all makes sense
if it's right but then this came along.
One of the reasons I put a lot of pressure
on the parenting thing
is because I have got
really educated by old people,
hanging out in retirement homes
with 70, 80, 90-year-olds.
Here's what happens.
Kids do things to make their parents happy
because they don't want confrontation
and they want it to be good.
They go be a lawyer or a doctor
because they don't want to fight
or have a bad relationship.
The problem is then they have
a 50 year bad relationship
because resentment and regret take over.
I don't want parents and kids to fight.
I'm not trying to get
into people's business.
I just know it's way
better for you to fight
for three or four years and
then have a great relationship
than get along fakely for nine
and then not like each other for life.
(audience applauding and cheering)
By the way, this whole
notion of you can do anything
and all this stuff, let me just
tell you, it's stupid hard.
Reality is, most of you are
just averagely talented.
Right?
You're not going to over-index
on anything too crazy.
Here's the good news.
This is not about how much money you make
or how talented you are.
This is about being happy.
Everybody here, regardless of
how fucking talented they are
in making money or art or what have you,
has shit that they're super into.
You love Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles?
Your whole life could be
about fucking Michelangelo.
(audience chuckling)
It could.
Here's what really fucks with me.
In this internet age,
you could have a podcast
around Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles,
you could buy Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle memorabilia
on Craigslist and Facebook and Etsy
and then flip it on a different platform
because you're so fucking knowledgeable,
because that's the
pizza-eating fucking Leonardo.
(audience laughing).
I'm just fascinated about what happens
when you go all in on your passion
and you're committed to it
and you use the infrastructure
of this, you living your life for 80 years
as the fucking Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle expert,
and this is getting funnier
to me by the second,
(audience laughing)
making $83K a year in ads
on your podcasts, the flip,
some miraculous reason
somebody paid you $2000
to go to a Bush League Comic-Con thing.
That person making $62,000
a year being the fucking TMT
fucking expert versus
them making $77,000 a year
being an admin in a company
where they hate their life
nine to five, that delta is something
I will go to the grave on
because it is what I want to
articulate to everybody,
the unbelievable level of
practicality to do shit
around stuff you like.
Here's the big part.
How many people under 40?
Let me just start with this group.
If you just really took
what I'm talking about,
became an expert at
Facebook and Instagram,
really understood,
the fact that you could
take a leap for two years,
move back in home, move in
together, cut your expenses,
I don't give a shit, the
fact that you can do that
for two or three years,
and if it doesn't work out
you can go back to getting
a job, that's nuts.
That's nuts.
We have to understand what's going on.
Why is Toys R Us going out of business?
Why are all these things happening?
It's happening because the internet
is eating up our society.
Why do we have such big opportunities?
Because everybody here can
start a competitor to Coca Cola,
which used to take $50 million
because you had to buy in
to Albertson's and to Safeway and Target
and you had to make it and
you had to fucking market it
on television and now it costs $200,000.
You make some, you slap it on Amazon, 3PL,
you run some Instagram influencer ads,
and you're in the game.
It's crazy.
It's absolutely crazy.
How's the painting coming along?
Look at this, is this amazing?
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
You have to listen.
I'm desperate to get you to go home
and rethink the whole thing.
I'm looking to speak
to two people tonight.
I'm being very serious.
I can't wait to the Q & A,
you can get me into a different direction.
I know who'll jump out
here and we'll give them
a big shout out for putting this together.
He'll take me in a different direction.
He wants to talk about the
macro situation of this town,
aka a lot of money's coming
and you're all going to
act like idiots.
(audience laughing)
You can ask me about
whatever the fuck you want.
But I'm telling you, what
I'm really looking for,
my mission, my selfish moment,
where I'm going with this talk,
is I'm looking to talk to two of you.
Two of you that are going to
go home, go deep for 60 hours
over the next three or four days,
actually take that jump, realize.
Listen, you all do know
what I'm talking about
is exactly like starting to ride a bike,
kissing a boy or girl,
or starting to swim.
All those things were scary as fuck.
Do you know how many people
here stood on the edge of a pool
for like 19 hours in their life?
(audience laughing)
Then you do it and you're like,
what the fuck was I doing?
(audience chuckling)
That's what's crazy about those things.
Those are big, right?
Kissing somebody when you
were a kid, that's big!
This is your life and it's the same game.
It's that normal in the
internet age to jump
around stuff you like.
The best part is you can do both.
You can work your nine to
five, still pay your bills.
You're like, cool Gary, this
is all very ideological,
but I have rent, I have some
loans, I've got this shit.
Cool, keep it.
What's crazy about the internet,
unlike what we grew up with
whereas if you wanted to
open up your store, your dream store,
you had to be there so by the
time you got home at seven,
you couldn't do that.
The fact that you can do this
from 7PM to two in the morning
until it means something,
enough to give you the courage
to jump off the other thing,
this is just practical.
The dream of being happy
and living your life
has actually become practical.
You're sitting on the information
but because it wasn't like
that for last 300 years,
you can't wrap your head around it.
And because it seems so crazy,
the idea of doing it and
nothing happens for six months,
makes you feel like it wasn't
meant to be and you get out.
Because you were built and groomed
within a school environment.
The end.
The only reason I'm successful
is because I got Ds and Fs
and I didn't listen.
I mean it.
It's how I see things differently.
You need somebody else
to have already done it.
You need to see the path.
I don't like paths.
I need blank slates.
This is a blank slate.
Do you understand that almost
every single person in their
basement, garage, and
closets are sitting between
$2,000 and $11,000 worth
of shit in their house
that they can post.
There's so much going on to me
that I can wrap my head around it.
That so many people here can
build a $50,000 to $500,000
a year business on Amazon just by going on
websites in China, buying something,
and then relisting it on Amazon.
That, my parents and I
had dinner in New York
and we had this nice dinner
and we were coming out
and our waitress ran, fancy place,
and the waitress ran out
and grabbed me and said,
thank you so much.
She said, my fiance was
out of a job for 19 months,
depressed, doing drugs, saw
one of your Instagram videos
and a year later on Amazon is
making $1.3 million a year.
(audience applauding)
Don't clap for me.
To me, this is fucking nuts.
So I'm just desperately trying
to find the two people here
that are not happy enough,
whatever that may be,
to realize this internet thing is big.
Look, if you're happy,
like really happy, do you.
Don't do anything.
Go home tonight and play
nine hours of Fortnight,
I don't give a fuck.
(audience chuckling)
But if you're not, you need
to desperately figure out
what's actually happening here.
These shocking things in
our society and the world
and big companies going out of business
and shocking results in elections
and all these different things,
it's happening because of the internet.
You should get your piece
because it's a long, long tale.
You should get your piece.
And you have to figure
out whether it's selling
or a service or whatever it may be,
like, what do you like?
What do you like?
Because the only way you're
going to work 16, 17 hours
on a weekend that will
actually there in two years,
is if you love retro clothes,
if you love strawberry fucking jam.
(audience chuckling)
If you love rare Rod Carew artifacts,
that's the only way, that was a good one,
that's the only way.
That's the only way.
So I am super excited about
the time that we're living in,
I love what's going on,
I love that the big companies are losing,
I love that the
establishment is in trouble.
I love it because I think
it's going to be better.
I think we're all going to be happier.
I really do.
When Best Buy goes out of business,
I don't see that as a negativity.
I see that as an opportunity.
I love that people are like,
oh, Best Buy shouldn't go out of business.
Best Buy put people out of business.
Best Buy put people out of business!
Everyone's like, this is
unfair, Walmart, like Target,
Target put people out of business.
How are you confused by this?
(audience chuckling lightly)
All of a sudden this was the
moment to stop capitalism?
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Because Target's here?
The point, and I appreciate
that, the good point to that
is this part.
Target put people out of business.
Ironically, if you really
play out my thesis,
the people that are going to
put Target out of business
are back to the small people.
(audience applauding)
You like that?
I actually don't give a fuck.
(audience laughing)
I don't care that the
small wins or the big wins,
I think it's all fair.
I think it's going to be super cool.
I could care less but I know it's true,
small merchants, downtowns,
then we move to the suburbs,
supermarkets, big box
retailers, they killed it, cool.
Now, we're going to be able to kill it
because you're going to make up,
somebody in here is going to
actually put two and two
together, go home, do work,
and in seven years is going to be selling
a million dollars a year
of peanuts on Amazon
and that's what chips away at Planters,
that's what chips away at Walmart and CVS
and that's what chips away at 7-11.
You are going to regret,
you made a big mistake
coming here tonight.
(audience chuckling)
I'm going to tell you why.
You made a big, big mistake
coming here tonight,
I'm telling you why.
I'm putting pressure on you to
do something with your life.
Everything I'm telling
you is about to happen
and will happen over the next 50 years
and in 31 years when you
did nothing about it,
I'm going to find you and make fun of you.
(audience laughing)
- [Female] Let's do it!
- Let's do it is right.
Who, just curious,
who would like to be a little bit happier?
Raise your fucking hand!
(audience hooting)
To me, news alert,
your president's not going
to fucking do it for you!
(audience laughing)
You're going to do it for you.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
Period.
That is the most interesting
shit to me of all time.
This internet thing is big.
It's real big.
It'll be bigger than we all thought.
The robots are going to kill
every one of our children.
(audience laughing)
But until then, let's
have some fucking fun.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
If you judge Facebook or
Instagram, if you do what Rod,
by the way, I respect his point of view,
but
if you judge this and you
use it in your business
or financial life,
based on how you view
it from a social stance,
you know what would have
been gangster about him,
he's like, I don't have one
but I have a huge Shopify
business on the side.
To me, the fact that you're
not doing Facebook or Instagram
or YouTube out of a social point of view,
at the detriment of your
business and happiness
and opportunity, is nuts.
Because you're mad that people
aren't talking to each other
in real life, you're leaving opportunity
on the table for yourself
is not a good idea.
I don't know how else to put it.
Now, if you're happy, once again,
I'm always worried when I talk,
I am not talking to anybody who's happy,
but the opportunity is
substantial and we a lot of times
impose our points of view.
You want your kid running outside more
so thus you're not running Facebook ads.
I mean, it's nuts.
I mean, and let me tell you
why this is so important.
You have to understand
I run a company called VaynerMedia.
Chase and Budweiser and
Pepsi and Johnson & Johnson,
the biggest companies in
the world, they are not,
listen to me my friends, this
is super duper important.
Let me tell you what happened
to little old me with Google.
I knew what was going on,
I was running the ads,
I didn't spend enough,
and then everybody else figured it out.
They started spending more
money and the word cabernet
went from 15 cents a click to $6.00.
When it costs $6.00 and only
one out of every 50 people
converted on the website,
it didn't become mathematically
worth it for me anymore
to run it.
Got it?
Facebook and Instagram cost
$4.00, $5.00, $6.00, $7.00
to have your picture or video
get in front of 1000 people
that you want.
In four years, after I'm
done convincing Chase
and Budweiser and Target
to spend 80% of their money
on Facebook instead of
5%, because, you know,
not one fucking person in
here watches a commercial
outside of Superbowl.
(audience chuckling)
Those ads, to get in front
of a 48-year-old female
that's into Frisbees in
Minnesota are going to go
from six bucks to $82 and your little
fucking Frisbee start-up
that started tonight
is going to not be growing as fast.
Everything I'm tell
you is about to go away
in the next four years.
Not the thesis of the internet,
but we're going to need
something to come along
like a Facebook, like a Google,
and take it from somebody
who lived in between Facebook and Google.
Those were six lonely years
when nothing was a deal.
It's a deal.
It's in your face.
I sit with these executives
and they spend 45 minutes
telling me that Facebook
is tearing the American
fucking democracy and
this is the worst thing
and we need to regulate it
and Facebook's too powerful.
Then we're done, them
pontificating their politics,
and we get into business
and I try to convince them
to spend more money on
Facebook, and they're like,
eh, but it doesn't, it
doesn't work for us.
I'm like, let me get this straight.
You think this platform is so powerful
that it can tear down America
(audience laughing)
but it's not powerful
enough to sell an extra
six-pack of beer you fucking idiot?
(audience laughing loudly)
(audience applauding)
You have 48 months to buy
up property in Manhattan
for a nickel on the dollar.
You're more than welcome not to.
The end.
Please take what I said tonight seriously.
This is the single best
land grab I've seen
in the last 20 years
and the single best one,
in my opinion, since this
country switched from radio.
(bottle rolling across the floor)
Jesus fucking Christ!
(audience laughing)
I'm kidding, I'm kidding!
Since this country, and
it was such a good one,
it was quiet too.
(audience laughing)
The transition to a mobile
first world with Facebook
and Instagram is the biggest
switch since we switched
from radio to television.
And Bob Hope and Lucille Ball
and Coca Cola and Budweiser
can tell you how that worked out.
Real good.
So I'll be doing my Bob
Hope/Lucille Ball thing over here,
I'd really like you to either figure out
if you want to be
Lucille Ball or Coca Cola
or some little version of it
because unlike television,
that had, you know,
three channels back then,
with 12 hours of programming,
this thing is unlimited.
You know what that means?
That means everybody here can
get their $60K, their $90K,
their $100K, their $400K, their
$700K, long tale, long tale.
Everybody used to want their
15 minutes of fame, right?
Now, everybody's famous to 15 people.
Got it?
Or 1500.
Or 15,000.
You're letting this moment slip.
I'm watching you let this moment slip.
I came here tonight to
wake you the fuck up.
Get woke and address this ridiculous,
ridiculous opportunity.
The best one you may ever have
in your entire fucking life.
Thank you.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
- Gary Vanerchuk.
(light jazz music)